hello good afternoon the met office is
predicting a 90 chance that the uk will
record its highest ever temperature on
either monday or tuesday
the government is putting in place extra
measures to help the ambulance service
cope with the extreme heat
a red warning for extreme heat will come
into force tomorrow covering an area
starting south of london and reaching as
far north as greater manchester and york
there's a 50 chance of the temperature
reaching 40 degrees on monday and
tuesday
and that would be a uk record now the
amber warning covers much of england and
will eventually take in all of wales and
southern scotland as it runs through
until tuesday night
now when the most extreme temperatures
hit on monday and tuesday it's warned
that the heat could cause adverse heat
health effects and impact services
across the uk
but people are also being warned that
even on a hot day open water can be
incredibly cold
a search is underway at arsley reservoir
in west yorkshire is after a man was
seen entering the water yesterday
evening well skye's fraser moored is
live for us now and fraser as tempting
as it may appear the advice repeatedly
is don't jump into open water
that's right yeah the emergency services
are repeating the dangers that come with
hot weather of course we know that the
heat warnings are coming into place some
are in place already today amber
warnings red warnings for tomorrow
saying that there could well be a risk
to life and one of those risks to life
is caused by people choosing to try and
cool down in dangerous places such as rd
reservoir here near wakefield and we've
heard another incident overnight
tragically a 16 year old boy in salford
keys in greater manchester getting into
difficulty in a canal there and sadly a
body has been recovered from that
investigation police say that
investigations are still continuing to
formally identify the body but they do
believe that it is that of a 16 year old
boy who was seen getting into difficulty
yesterday evening his family have been
supported by specially trained officers
especially trained officers to assisting
the family of the man who is still the
subject of an ongoing search here at
arnsley near wakefield he was seen going
into the water at about 5 30 last night
getting into difficulty the emergency
services were called helicopters came
we've seen uh inshore rescue and search
units uh on the river uh on the uh
reservoir sorry uh in
in various uh in various boats and so on
and underwater search teams are on site
at the moment although i have to say
there doesn't seem to be much activity
on the reservoir
certainly for the last couple of hours
or so although the police do assure me
that the searches are continuing we've
seen a scene of crime forensic van
appear in the last hour or so whether or
not that means that
that something has been discovered we
are still not sure police haven't
confirmed that as yet but they say that
the searches are ongoing and they say
that this is another example of
highlighting the dangers of swimming in
open water any water that's below 15
degrees c
is deemed to be cold water according to
the emergency services and any water of
that temperature or below can cause the
body to go into cold water shock as it's
known once the body enters the water it
effectively creates a muscle spasm and a
breath spasm which if you're underwater
at the time can of course mean that the
lungs are almost instantly filled with
water and the muscles are in spasms so
it's very difficult to swim the rnli say
that their advice is float to survive if
you do find yourself in cold water you
do find yourself getting into difficulty
try and just remain as calm as possible
float on your back until your body gets
used to the water shock and then your
muscles will start to work again and you
can then begin to try and swim to safety
the advice is if you see anyone getting
into difficulty in cold water or in
bodies of water such as this to contact
the emergency services on 999 and ask
for
the fire service there are also many
unseen dangers of swimming in in open
waters such as reservoirs lakes rivers
and so on there can be all sorts of
detritus and debris on the bottom there
can be underwater filters uh and sluices
and so on which can cause underwater
currents which might not be visible from
the surface can cause people to get into
serious difficulty there so people are
being warned
to take things very seriously to take
the threat of cold water very seriously
no matter how warm the air temperature
might be lots of large bodies of water
are still very very cold and can still
cause the body to go into shock the
advice take care if you see anyone in
difficulty call the emergency services
absolutely frasier thank you there's
fraser moore there live in wakefield
well skies meteorologist kirsty mccabe
has the latest on how the heatwave will
develop
it's already extremely hot in places and
the temperatures are going to continue
to rise over the coming days across the
uk and ireland the peak of the heat is
likely to be monday and tuesday but even
today we're looking at highs around 32
or 33 degrees as i mentioned the
temperatures are getting even higher now
there's currently a 90 chance we're
going to break the all-time uk
temperature record which is 38.7 celsius
we're likely to see that record being
broken on monday and again on tuesday
tuesday could be even hotter there is a
60 chance that monday or tuesday but
more like tuesday we're going to see
temperatures over 40 degrees now that'll
be the first time ever the uk has seen
temperatures over 40 degrees and at the
moment it looks more likely than not
that it's going to happen
and it's not just going to be hot by day
it's going to be very uncomfortable and
muggy and hot by night the area is quite
dry at the moment coming all the way
from north africa it's crossing western
europe in towards the uk across western
europe it's been extremely hot with
wildfires as well across the uk we'll
see the temperature rising as this hot
dry air from north africa heads our way
but the humidity levels will increase as
we go through the week so tuesday night
wednesday starts to see things getting
very uncomfortable and even though the
temperatures themselves will dip down i
think it'll feel a lot more muggy and
uncomfortable as that humidity rises
now it's not just hot by day it's hot by
night we could see some all-time
temperature records broken for the
overnight lows not that low we're
looking at maybe 24 or 25 degrees in
some of the urban centres such as
birmingham and london especially monday
night into tuesday morning so the
dangers come with this heat not just by
day but by night there's a lot of stress
on the human body and that's why the met
office has issued these rare extreme
heat warnings the amber warning
extending across much of england wales
southern eastern parts of scotland and
then that red warning across many parts
of england that's where we like to see
these really high temperature numbers at
the moment the area most likely to see
the highest values it's going to be
north of london up towards sort of
lincolnshire the veil of york area
possibly again cambridgeshire that's
where the current record is was taken in
2019 that area could again see some of
the highest numbers so
very hot an unusual smell of weather
i know a lot of people talk about 1976
and that was an extremely hot and dry
and quite a long hot dry spell of
weather this is fairly short but it's
more intense the heat exceptional and
quite dangerous
skies meteorologist
kirsty mccabe there with the latest now
the nhs is bracing itself for a surge of
patience as temperatures saw over the
coming days the government's putting in
place extra measures to help the
ambulance service cope with the
increased demand including more call
handlers joining me now is acute lead at
the nhs confederation rory dayton who's
in west yorkshire and rory what kind of
pressure then will the heat wave put on
our nhs
uh good afternoon thank you for having
me i i think we'll see uh pressure in in
in all sorts of places in the nhs
ambulance services we expect to be
particularly stressed and emergency
departments as well we know that the
london ambulance service for example
um pre-pandemic would take about six
thousand calls a day
uh we're currently at about seven
thousand and they're planning for about
eight thousand calls
on uh monday tuesday wednesday
places like gp practices will be under
significant pressure there'll be
significant pressure for services like
community nursing as well
and we're starting to see
some hospital trusts cancelling some of
their elective procedures as well to
create capacity for that emergency care
and we've heard some of the advice you
know stay hydrated etc what should
people do to keep themselves safe
the the advice is that is absolutely
right it is about staying indoors uh at
the hottest weather it's about wearing
uh sun cream about uh wearing hats um
about staying hydrated and perhaps most
importantly it's about looking after
friends families and neighbors
particularly people living on their own
and making sure that we're we're not
leaving people uh on their own
at this time so so people families can
help at the same time
and sunscreen for all skins isn't it
because i think some people with darker
skin
people with my skin tone may think
actually you don't need um sunscreen but
actually the reality is you do don't you
uh absolutely it's very much for for
everybody and there are some important
messages
at the moment the temperatures that we
like to see monday tuesday wednesday are
not going to be normal temperatures
there is going to be something different
going on and we need to prepare
ourselves for it and it's proper
sunscreen as well it's not
uh factor five factor 10 as i perhaps
used to wear in the in the 80s it's uh
it's proper 30 and 50 sunblock that
we're looking for absolutely and also
it's not just um older people who are
vulnerable because that's the
misconception that i think a lot of us
have but it looks as though from what
we're hearing that anybody really can be
at risk
anybody can be uh at risk at all we are
particularly concerned about people
living on their own uh and and older
people as well but um
anybody can be at this risk and it's not
something to be underestimated the
country uh doesn't see temperatures at
this kind of level and they bring uh
increased risk of mortality when they
when temperatures get this
and what are the signs to look out for
if somebody's struggling for example if
they're struggling with a heat stroke
for example how do you know that this is
what's happening to them
the important thing i think is to to ask
for advice if you are concerned about
people and if you are worried about it
then then one one one will give you uh
good advice so so don't um
you know exercise real caution and and
be really sensible about it and take
good early advice
on it if you are concerned